hi this is kevin van ORD standing in for
reviewer Daniel Starkey to tell you
about super smash brothers yes there's
so much raw joy to be found in Super
Smash Brothers for the 3ds the game's
new emphasis on competitive modes will
be Kindle that competitive spirit within
you the trophies for characters like
pac-man and Megaman will unearth trivia
for games that may have been before your
time and the excellent soundtrack will
fuel your nostalgia for games like Zelda
and Pokemon
unlike most fighting games there are no
life bars and extensive button
combinations to learn in Super Smash
Brothers each characters attacks are
easy to learn and the goal is to rack up
damage to knock your opponent further
and further away eventually you'll be
able to knock your folk clear off the
stage it's like a trumped up glitzy
version of sumo wrestling and it's
brilliant if you're skilled or lucky
enough you can stay on a stage even
after taking more than your fair share
of hits this adds a layer of tension to
most matches as dealing the most damage
doesn't always guarantee your win the
3ds game lacks some widely panned
mechanics from the last game in the
series Super Smash Brothers Brawl gone
is the random tripping as well as the
general feeling of the low gravity
floatiness in their stead are a bevy of
subtle new additions aimed at both
casual players and the core crowd the
result feels more honest and broadly
appealing than
consideration
there are numerous features introduced
in Smash Brothers 3ds mid-battle items
are weirder and have a wider variety
effects including quite a few that can
deliver one bit Kos and another that
will give you an extra life levels and
fighters also have new additions to help
keep fights meaning fresher this time
around at higher levels of play
Nintendo's made tweaks to almost every
area from grabs to ledge guarding even
classic Smash Brothers concepts like
directional influence have been
overhauled the main cast of characters
has balloons 249 which is a far cry from
the 12 found in the original Nintendo 64
release almost all of the characters
played differently stages are similarly
varied and have a wide variety of
hazards and tricks to keep players
engaged at monster
they smash mothers stages have always
been incredibly diverse and it's great
to see that the imaginative levels
haven't been lost in the transition from
living room consoles to handheld it may
however cause some problems for your
hands and wrists playing on a small
handheld system is vastly different to
play on console controllers which are
engineered to be extremely comfortable
to use for hours on end it's worth
mentioning that if you're going to be
picking this game up you might want to
try the demo of it if you're using one
of the smaller 3ds models to make sure
your hands don't cramp up
Smash Brothers 3ds has two online modes
to choose from for fun and for glory the
former has the full standard list of
stages available and signature Smash
Brothers items like the beam sword and
homerun bat will appear regularly in the
latter every stages of variants of the
final destination location meaning it's
completely flat and has no special
characteristics items are banned from
these matches in an effort to more
closely mimic at the kind of a
competitive environment that has grown
up around the series single-player modes
are pretty minimal on the 3ds especially
compared to Super Smash Brothers Brawl
but what's here is fantastic classic
mode is back and while the 3ds version
might seem a little bit shorter than in
previous games it's also by far the best
before each run you'll wager gold coins
that you've earned by playing matches
the more you wager the tougher the
fights but that also ups the rewards and
collectables you can earn at the end
you'll collect your winnings possibly
unlock a new character and do something
else or play through again which is what
you'll probably do a lot
you can spend the gold you pick up in an
in-game store to unlock through trophies
or you can play other modes like trophy
rush which costs a certain amount of
gold per second of play in all of these
modes the goal is to unlock more of
Smash Brothers many many many secrets
hidden stages characters items to
upgrade your Me's and trophies all pull
from the Nintendo Pantheon and are all
meant to be something special to some
fans somewhere what matters most is that
Super Smash Brothers 3ds just feels
great to play Smash Brothers it's good
to have you back